سلامات معكم
[موسيقى]
اينا نصح من 5 الصبح عشان نبور الخ نا
نمشي اكثر من 6 كيلو عشان نع
ومش فارقه كثير اذا كان حلو او
مالح صنا نشحن جوالاتنا بالشارع عن اي حدا
عنده طاقه شمسيه مش بس لحالك انت وكل
الحاره وكل المنطقه بتشحن
عنده يمكن هذا الديو الاخير لي الي
الاحتلال قنابل فيفور على منطقه مشروع بيت
لاهيا وقنابل صوتيه
مخيفه والقى ب مناشير باخلاء المنطقه
وطبعا كل المنطقه اخلت
تقريبا الموت والدمار بكل غزه الاحلام
كلها تحطمت الصغار بس بيبكوا
الاحتلال ما بيرحم ولا شيخ ولا طفل ولا
نساء ولا بحم حدا كله تحت مرمى النيران كل
المدنيين كل شي في غزه هو مستهدف ما ضلش
شي احنا في غزه مش بخير بتات احنا في غزه
مش بخير بتات احنا خلص بدنا توقفوا لنا ها
الحرب احنا بدنا حرب وقفوا الحرب
ياب
يا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
was احنا بشر زيناي بشر كل
العالم
كان في عننا احلام كثير
كبيره بس للاسف اليوم احلامنا
انه لو
استشهدنا نستشهد جسد
واحد انه الناس
تعرفنا ما نكون اشلاء و نحط
بكيس انه لما نستشهد يكون في كفن
لنا وندفن بكبر وقت راح تخلص هاي
الحرب ومين راح يضل يحكي للناس شو صار
فينا شو احنا عشنا شو
شفنا
عينينا